una democrata que desata amores y odios
Nancy pelosi la hasta ahora presidenta
de la cámara de representantes ha sido
pieza clave en las iniciativas de los
dirigentes de su partido
es un día feliz para nuestro país porque
joeyden es un unificador porque está
decidido a unir a la gente
ejerció como líder de la cámara
inicialmente de 2007 a 2011 en 2010
ayudó a aprobar el famoso plan de salud
de Obama conocido como Obama Care en
2019 cuando volvió a liderazgo de la
cámara fue fundamental en los planes de
ayuda económica para los estadounidenses
afectados por la pandemia de Kobe 19 y
decisiva en los proyectos de Joe biden
Pero ha sido una piedra en el zapato
para su principal opositor el ex
presidente Donald Trump a quien le
inició dos juicios políticos con el
ánimo de destituirlo el primero en 2019
por acusaciones de retención indebida de
ayuda militar a Ucrania y otro en 2021
por incitar el ataque del 6 de enero en
el Capitolio
hoy se produce un vergonzoso salto a
nuestra democracia sin embargo no puede
isodirnos de nuestra responsabilidad de
validar la elección de
también ha sido fuerte en la política
exterior en agosto de este año enfureció
a China tras visitar la diputada isla de
Taiwán ser la cara más reconocida de la
cámara de representantes le ha causado
también problemas de seguridad en el
ataque al Capitolio la masa irrumpió en
su oficina mientras gritaba queremos a
Nancy Asimismo el 28 de octubre en su
casa en San Francisco un hombre atacó
brutalmente a su esposo con un martillo
mientras decía donde esta Nancy la
presidenta podría perder su cargo cuando
se define A quién será la mayoría de la
cámara de representantes